i wish i had an accent like you do have
an accident yeah you do have it's an
american accent
no i'm leaving la right now
bye guys it was nice knowing you okay
because i grew up in canada i was born
in morocco my first language is french
oh and so i think when i first moved to
la i had a bit of like a canadian accent
right you lose that it goes right
um but i do find myself sometimes
sounding a little bit la-esque and it's
very scary i i don't know like
that that's that's my boundary
as soon as someone tells me i start
sounding like like a valley girl i have
to go i have to go back to my room
oh my [ __ ] god like that kind of
bible the issue is you hear those kind
of things so much yeah and then
sometimes you'll say it ironically
because it feels funny and good to say
ironically
then all of a sudden it's not so ironic
it's like
everyone would say bro ironically and
now everyone says bro it's like saying
boston or
it is though it is at first i'm like
this is like cringe as [ __ ] among us why
would people laugh at among us and then
i start laughing and among us
uncontrollably five months in i'm like
okay yeah we learned from the charity
stream that god's funny bone is just
someone saying among us but just bass
boosters
just laugh at it every time
yeah exactly yeah
do you get like annoyed people like you
don't sound canadian anymore i feel like
attacked people say that to me when
they're like you don't sound british
enough i know what you mean yeah like i
was [ __ ] born there what do you think
what is this right now like i feel
really tough
this is a safe space for like a podcast
wait wait so how how long were you in
canada for
um for between the ages of four to
twenty it's like 16 years oh okay yeah
okay yeah okay be honest with me and
like i can take it how american do i
sound oh yeah like very like that's a
hundred people yeah i did yeah yeah i i
i'm american or like i live in l.a no
american american i'm american because
like americans
like saying american accent is just like
the most neutral accent you could yeah
it's like the default skin in fortnite
that's where the image you'll be able to
tell a canadian from an american if the
canadian didn't have like an intense
canadian accent because i don't think a
lot of us are out here like a boot this
fake
i mean there are some people there are
some people i've met that have like that
kind of you know a buddhist yeah yeah
but like i've i've met so many creators
just on this trip alone yeah where i'm
like i always thought you were american
until you told me like like you for
example i didn't know you were canadian
you know so it's like happening it's
really hard to hear something i mean
obviously if you're like you know from
quebec or something or like you know
where it's like a very strong accent
right yeah yeah obviously if you're xqc
i can tell you're not quite from america
but like yeah for your accent i have no
idea you just sound american to me for
me i can't tell the difference between
american and canadian accents but
sometimes you get like you meet someone
and they just like they have the
canadian energy you know what i mean
why what is the canadian image i can
tell you the canadian energy is when you
go into a place and you're saying hey
can i go to the bathroom
the toilet not like the washroom or like
where can i go
you know it's like specific words wait
when you say bagel i thought i thought i
thought bathroom was like what americans
say is a washroom
i've never heard anyone say wash fruit
i've never heard anything
yeah do they say toilet in america can i
go to the toilet fred like in french
they say toilet in america
i don't even i don't i mostly hear the
word bathroom yeah like okay then i
meant washroom i think when i first came
to la i used to say washroom a lot of
people were like
yeah it's kind of like when you're in
america and you just say where's the loo
you know i don't know like i've seen we
say that we see a toilet in the uk right
yeah we say toilet we see toilet oh my
god oh my god have you have you
forgotten connor have you forgotten i i
do forget because i've been so
americanized
yeah
and everyone gives me so much copium
i did a [ __ ] stream with ludwig and
he made a video about it and it was oh i
was doing well then a lot of the
comments were like i was waiting for the
british guy to turn up because there's a
british guy in the title and uh this guy
isn't british i live lived in britain
and he doesn't sound british and it's
like oh oh just because my accent
changed a little bit i'm not from the
country anymore [ __ ] off you sound
pretty [ __ ] british yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] british
the more the louder i get the more
british i sound better so if i'm around
if i if i'm around british people it
goes british if i'm around american
people it goes more american yeah okay
random thought curious what you guys
think do you think
like actors and celebrities that are
known for being from a certain place
will intentionally try to like continue
to force their accent for a really long
time because i could see that like
they'll move to america or something be
here for a long time maybe lose the
accent but then they like have to
retrain themselves to keep the accent
dude i feel like
yeah yeah like he's about to start doing
that yeah i i swear i have to do that
so actually i've been doing that for a
very long time um
i feel i feel especially like something
about like the american accent is very
easily transferred
yeah yeah it's just speaking you're just
you're just enunciating all your work
except for h that's that's the only
thing uh you know yeah
h
herbs herb herbs that's the only thing i
don't understand everything else i'm
like okay it makes sense why you kind of
like made it very clear and very
enunciated that's how you say it right
yeah enunciated
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and the other
thing is
i heard that listen british accents are
so fun to do
[Applause]
um canadians say x y zed not x y z we
say x y z as well yeah
yeah same with the british oh yeah my
man yeah are you as canadians say zed
yeah i always say said so because you
used to be britain
i guess
yeah like if your accent's really [ __ ]
then it's like all right you better work
on it before you talk to me yeah yeah
yeah
do you feel like uh you've a bond to the
queen as your as your head of state
growing up
a little bit because i think
no i kid you not okay we were taught
that quite a bit in school but then
afterwards i'm like queen who what yeah
i'm not american i'm not canadian
i i belong to the world
i'm a citizen of the world
so can you go back to your like
i guess like your accent you grew up
with any time you want to because i
guess it wasn't that much of an
it depends like whereabouts in canada
were you from like were you from like
vancouver or like
i was from middle of buff like nowhere
calgary
no actually the accents that you guys
probably think of when you think of
canadian accents are from the like
middle provinces yeah yeah manitoba
alberta yeah very who mega lol i'm the
kind of who megalo that's like i'm two
hours from toronto
so i pretend i'm from toronto but i'm
not i'm from a very boring little city
right right right right so you have the
small town rep right i guess a little
bit
just a small town girl
no honestly the older i get the this
sounds so the more appreciative i am of
my upcoming because
i feel like it was just so chill like a
small pretty wholesome like
kind of multicultural town and
living in america you i feel like you
are much more exposed oh yeah to all the
downsides of living in america not just
living in america you're living in la as
well you know yeah a very very intense
city it's couldn't be pretty much the
opposite of what you grew up with